we have to be here it's quarter to eight
in about
10 minutes from cern there's going to be
a
press
conference actually a seminar first the
belief is the feeling is that they're
going to announce
the discovery of a new particle yeah
maybe the higgs
i haven't heard that uh the evidence
that was presented back in december has
disappeared
and so but it's still officially a
secret yeah so higgs higgs will should
be there he's he's one of those that
have been invited and yeah i think he'll
be there he's in his 80s now but all
this work was done
uh in around 1964.
so it's going on for 50 years ago it's a
long time 48 years ago
this work was published so they've been
waiting a long time we've all been
waiting a long time
uh for maybe this uh today
it's wearing away i wonder how many
thousands of people are
i'm a bit nervous about this bit brady
because in december these were really
technical seminars um and in fact
it was quite difficult to pick out where
they were saying
look this is
this is potential evidence but on this
occasion given the worldwide publicity
they must at some stage
say we think we found something new they
must unless they haven't there he is
that's peter hicks
yeah
i was at summer school in
1985 in edinburgh and um
someone
on the blackboard as peter hicks came
into a meeting they'd drawn a picture
and they'd put a
image of peter higgs's face and they'd
put a superman cape
but they'd call the sh super higgs
so i think what they will have is two
seminars
one by the there are two main
uh detectors which are which are built
to discover the higgs one's called atlas
and of course one's called cms as we
know
like a school boy in a candy shop a
number of people commented
wow
this is it it's the detector
so the spokesperson for cms is going to
give a seminar i think it'll be about 20
minutes 25 minutes
and he'll review
the data that they've got
looked at another way you can ask what's
the uh discovery potential
now the probability that the background
would fluctuate up to a given signal the
size of the standard model can you
explain to me the difference between a
higgs field and a higgs boson yeah the
higgs field is is a a field is just
something that has a value
and it's got a value everywhere it and
the the the the higgs is called us it's
got it doesn't have a direction it just
has a value it's got some value here and
some value there
if you excite an electromagnetic field
you'll create a photon and we all
happily see that with coming down to us
now
the equivalent for the higgs field is if
you excite the higgs field you will
create a higgs boson particle and that's
what's been detected it's the excitation
of the higgs field which in turn
requires a lot of energy that's why you
have to fire the protons in so the idea
is you smack the protons together those
protons then that energy in the in that
regime
can be enough to
excite the higgs field which is
permeating the whole universe in that
regime excites the higgs field and then
that can generate a higgs particle which
will then decay almost instantaneously
and it's got these because it can couple
to all the particles in the universe it
can decay in a whole set of ways
different ways some of them
via creating photons others by creating
the w and z particles others by decaying
into quarks
so and those are the channels
and the the ones that they've been able
to get the best statistics on are the
ones where the higgs decays into the two
photons and the ones where the higgs
decays into the four leptons
we use the page number
and we've concluded by saying that we
have observed a punchline
with a mass of 125.3
plus or minus 0.6 gv
at 4.9 standard deviations
thank you
we saved the punch line to the last
slide
ed when we excite the electromagnetic
field and get a photon
that photon seems to last a very long
time it can travel across the universe
how come when we excite the higgs field
and create a higgs boson this thing
vanishes so quickly
so a photon is massless
and it's so it's got um it
it doesn't have anything to decay into
the higgs particle is a very very
massive particle it's got a mass of
about a hundred and if if this is
correct today
a mass of about 133 times that of a
proton which we also think of a failure
as a massive particle and because it can
it can interact with so many other
particles with lower masses
it can decay
so it it doesn't want to hang around
it's this massive thing that's just
feeling a bit
you know it it it can't move very far
and so it just decays there good morning
atlas is very pleased to present here
today
uh update results on the standard model
league searches based on status of
aggressive searches until this morning
this will last five minutes
so they seem to be having a best fit
value
of about
126.5 gb
i'm not quite sure that's slightly
different
so far from
cms so the key number that they've been
giving is the what they think of the
mass of this particle is they're not
calling it the higgs
they've been getting the mass of it and
the mass they've given in terms of a
unit called
giga electron volts an electron volt is
an energy it's the energy required to
lift an electron through one volt in
terms of joules that's about 10 to the
minus 19 joules it's very small a giga
electron volt is
a billion electron volts the mass scale
that they're finding is about 125
gv that's the the mass that was being
given by cms and about 126 gv being
given by
atlas
so something to compare it with
a proton which makes up uni has a mass
of around one gv
so this is a in back fact just a bit
less than a gv so this is about 130
times
the mass of a proton so it's it's
effectively you know if you think of an
atom
an atom a heavy atom which is made up of
say 50 protons and 50 neutrons or
something this is about that mass right
it's it's that's one particle
i think we all have to be proud of these
i think he is that's peter higgs
i think he was crying
that must be quite an emotional time for
him
on a teaching basis it's fantastic
you'll be able to now say this is the
complete picture of the standard model
however let me put in one caveat here
which is what they haven't been able to
demonstrate and which is why i think
they're not yet saying this is the
standard model higgs is is it the
standard model higgs or is it actually
a more complicated object that maybe
that is
this part of it looks like the standard
model but there are other bits
that might yet show up as a layman i
would now say
i think we have it
you agree yeah
that's the director general of cern
saying that
[Applause]
good stuff
good stuff